we understand that she waited to release
the film until the people of India could
have unobstructed access via the
director yes it's an idea which came to
me that's why we also enhanced the
theater experience multiform by bringing
power 3d the sound effect was so good
that you will never get it watching it
on a television screen so on one side I
wanted to keep the ecosystem of the
industry intact not just rush into some
new technology which i think is good for
money and but I think it's also been
proven right in Hollywood like arbitrage
has gone as brassed more through VOD
video on demand then the theatrical but
that doesn't mean that the theatricals
have gone down it's only that there's
another venue we have discovered to
monetize our phone it's like how we had
only few theaters and we built many
theaters many screens and multiplied
them I mean met with the demand your
supplies met with the demand and that's
what I was trying to do with DTH there's
a little bit of scuttling but south of
India has understood the vision and
they're staying with me the North is yet
to fully understand
are you finding theaters in the states
that are able to accommodate that
special sound not America has about 25
to 30 theaters if I know right I might
be wrong but Tamil Nadu one state one
state in the whole of the country has 25
theaters now they'll have 30 by next
year and the sound is incredible when
you hear it you'll understand why I am
promoting it I mean when when I started
there were only two other directors but
good enough predecessors to have that
was
mr. Lucas and mr. Spielberg they were
working on the sound when I decided to
go on our 3d
you